[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en la
adolescencia a partir de los últimos
casos de abuso de acoso escolar y sobre
todo de la crisis de la Salud Mental que
nos deja el escenario de la postpandemia
para ello nos acompañan tres invitados
en nuestro estudio ya de saludo Mario
Eugenia uriburues psicóloga clínica
bienvenido bienvenida Israel Ayala
periodista especializado en nuevas
tecnologías bienvenido Gracias y Ariadna
cancio psicóloga psicoterapeuta
bienvenida
las crisis de la adolescencia en plural
hoy en Primera Plana
a menudo Los Adolescentes es un público
al que nos dirigimos poco en los medios
de comunicación y eso que es una
experiencia vital por la que
absolutamente Todos hemos pasado pero
que es verdad que cambia con el contexto
en tiempos de uso excesivo de pantallas
y de redes sociales la adolescencia vive
sus propias crisis con características
determinadas la pandemia no atacó tanto
su salud Física Pero sí lo hizo en
muchos casos con la Salud Mental un
informe publicado recientemente en
España señala que el acoso escolar ha
repuntado en los últimos meses y el
aspecto físico es el principal motivo
aquí en Francia el último caso que ha
traído la consternación es el de Lucas
un adolescente gay de 13 años que se
suicidó hace dos semanas en un contexto
de acoso escolar denunciado por su
familia repasemos algunas portadas que
nos deja la prensa El semanario el
Exprés acaba de dedicar un número aquí
en Francia este asunto con la portada
juventud hecha trizas entre redes
sociales y adicción le entrevista la
primera dama de Francia Brigitte macron
quien ha hecho del bullying su combate
personal la revista news week engloba
los temas de los que hoy hablamos en una
frase un solo testimonio me siento
invisible empecemos por ahí sentirse
invisible María Eugenia esta frase
retrata esa etapa para muchos chicos y
chicas
bueno primero la adolescencia
se puede hablar de adolescencia más o
menos a partir de estamos algunos
expertos hablan de 10 11 años hasta los
25 Aquí es muy grande
es difícil de los hombres es todavía más
alargada
efectivamente o hablar de invisibilidad
o tratar de bueno de captar un momento
específico a la adolescencia es complejo
porque efectivamente hay toda esta
multiplicidad de momentos de edades de
deseos y de cuestiones que van
atravesando pero la adolescencia Es un
periodo muy particular donde hay que
estar muy
perceptivo
a la posibilidad de estas sensaciones de
invisibilidad que a veces están hablando
de cuestiones depresivas o este pueden
ir hasta tendencias suicidaria Así que
la cuestión de la invisibilidad
definitivamente no es presente para
todos Aunque puede ser presente que sea
invisible en los medios No
necesariamente siempre
que se presente así en la adolescencia
Todos hemos pasado por la adolescencia
Israel hemos sentido la presión social
hemos sido hormonas con patas digamos
por caricaturizar un poco a la
adolescente lo que cambia es el contexto
no lo que no hemos sufrido todos Quizás
es el ciberbullying las pensiones en las
redes sociales las nuevas tecnologías es
lo que cambian el escenario actual no
exactamente Y ahorita que estás tocando
este tema de la invisibilidad justamente
las redes sociales lo que permiten es
dar visibilidad a temas que quizás no
podrías tratar en la vida real no
entonces las redes sociales sobre todo
con la pandemia cambiaron la manera en
que los adolescentes se relacionan en
que los adolescentes estudian por
ejemplo estamos ante una generación que
durante más de un año vivió educándose a
través de zoom conferencias en línea
clases en línea estamos en una
generación de adolescentes que
privilegia lo simple no la información
inmediata la información rápida estamos
en una generación que creció con
Instagram no que creció con los retos de
tiktok por ejemplo claro vamos a hablar
luego porque las redes sociales vamos a
hablar con Israel las redes sociales
tienen su componente positivo y su
negativa y su negativo hay de todo la
pandemia en cualquier caso afectó a
muchos adolescentes más en un plano
mental que físico comentaba yo antes y
quizás Ariana eso está lastrando hoy a
muchos adolescentes cómo les marco la
pandemia porque quizá es el otro
componente que Define en la construcción
de la adolescencia es necesario ese pasa
de la figura parental y la autoridad
para hacer su propia construcción con
identificaciones y construcción de sí
mismo con los pares no entonces
necesaria esa salida no de la relación
familiar
intrafamiliar para salir al exterior al
perder el contacto de la escuela de las
de los ritos de la adolescencia en sí
los momentos de salida de la escuela de
entrada todo pasa a ser virtual un
finalmente
complica esto no complica la
construcción de sí mismo la pregunta por
sí mismo y la separación de los padres
claro es que la pandemia María Eugenia
trajo consigo una contradicción brutal
los adolescentes que tienen una
necesidad de libertad y en cambio se les
impone el confinamiento
qué supuso esta privación de libertad
para todas las generaciones de
adolescencia su boca será un
acontecimiento histórico que cuando lo
estudiemos marcó a Esta generación de
adolescentes claramente no efectivamente
marcó a bueno a los adultos por lo
general que son los destinatarios que
miran el programa
efectivamente los marcó a los adultos le
movió la estructura a los Adolescentes
Por supuesto que muchísimo más a ver el
miedo a los padres a la incomprensión la
incertidumbre esto generó mucho mucha
mucho más dolor en los adolescentes que
no tenía que de ya la adolescencia
tienen una crisis de los referentes
que ponen a prueba los límites y las
referentes paternos efectivamente
durante la pandemia bueno los casos de
por ejemplo justamente Para volver a la
cuestión del suicidio la cuestión de
malestar en la adolescencia fue fue muy
patente la demanda además con montones
de hospitales cerrados y con los
recortes que ha habido en la Salud
Mental en Francia hacen que si a la
adolescencia se perdió bueno se
perdieron muchas muchas vidas también la
pandemia sin duda disparó la dependencia
de pantallas Israel y una pregunta que
se hacen todos los padres es cuando hay
que comenzar cuando la dependencia pasa
a ser patológica En qué punto hay que
preocuparse de la dependencia de las
pantallas Cómo definimos ese punto qué
criterios tenemos Israel Mira yo creo
que allí una palabra que es súper
importante y a lo mejor Mis colegas
tienen una definición más precisa pero
es la dopamina qué es lo que hace cuando
estás en una red social qué es lo que
hace cuando estás en tiktok qué es lo
que haces cuando está estás en tinder te
genera una reacción positiva y eso
genera dopamina y entre más dopamina
haya mucha más adicción va a haber no
Entonces por ejemplo simplemente las
estadísticas muestran que las
generaciones de entre 13 y 23 años es
decir los adolescentes que tienen entre
13 y 23 años pasan cada día más de 4
horas en redes sociales como tik Tok
entonces hay que plantearse la pregunta
de bueno si los adolescentes están
consumiendo todo este tipo de contenidos
que a veces pueden ser contenidos tanto
como desinformativos cómo vamos a
regular eso cómo vamos a controlar
digamos los padres que a lo mejor los
padres no saben cómo funciona tiktok y
no saben que existe no Y además puede
que existan tendencias o challengers
retos que se han vuelto virales y que
son completamente desconocidos por los
adultos es un Mundo paralelo
absolutamente para muchos padres y para
lo que cambian esta época los conflictos
de la adolescencia en todas las épocas
más o menos O sea se repiten son una y
otra vez lo mismo lo que cambia es la
forma y en esta época Me parece que hay
dos cosas importantes para pensar es la
entrada de la adolescente en la vida
pública mucho antes antes en una época
era a partir de los 18 donde adolescente
podía opinar o participar a la sociedad
hoy en día a través de la tecnología
pueden empezar muy temprano a opinar y
ahí se generan cosas maravillosas
también no solo el demonio de la
tecnología pero la posibilidad de
militar de de importancia de investigar
no lo que también producen la simetría
con el adulto porque ahora es el adulto
el que va a preguntarle al adolescente
cómo funciona Cómo se hace cómo refresco
la página no entonces Esto hace que para
el adolescente se haya una caída de los
referentes de la figura porque
ya no sabe mucho el adulto María Añadir
algo más sí efectivamente es importante
estar atento justamente a la viralidad
de ciertas situaciones pensamos en
angell o él ella conozco gracias a
Instagram creó su carrera su público no
muy creativo también muy tiene
muchísimos puntos positivos Pero bueno
que el adulto pueda hablar con el
adolescente ser consciente de la
viralidad de la instantaneidad y de esta
exposición esta exposición que trae
riesgos que trae riesgos y como Ellos
están en la impulsividad el adolescente
está en la impulsividad va a pasar al
acto rápidamente va a tener mucha
necesidad de escribir y de decir cosas
esto bueno con los emoticones permite
exprimir las emociones diferentes no
Bueno es muy positivo esto pero
efectivamente está esta imposibilidad el
pasaje al acto y hay que poder
ayudarlos con lo que se puede llegar a
generar
adolescentes pero no las herramientas no
son las mismas de las que dispone el
adolescente es necesario para el adulto
también encontrar una posición siempre
es yo encuentro una y otra vez en
consulta vienen muchos adolescentes y
que no hay como síntomas clínicos
simplemente es que el adolescente
necesita un espacio para hablar no un
espacio que no encuentra por ahí en la
comunicación con los padres porque hay
como este juego no el adulto dice el
adopción te hace nada hace nada o se la
pasa todo el día en el teléfono y la
adolescencia está haciendo un gran
trabajo que tiene que ver con la
construcción de sí mismo con encontrar
la autenticidad con en la masa poder
diferenciarse y no caer simplemente
pasar a la vida adulta en un mensaje de
ser uno más el suicidio de un
adolescente gay de 13 años Lucas
sometido acoso escolar a conmocionado a
estos últimos días a Francia cómo se
ponen los mecanismos María Eugenia para
que este tipo de casos no se repitan qué
mecanismos hay
primero la formación gracias a bueno ha
habido nuevas leyes efectivamente en
Francia la nueva ley del 2 de marzo
considera que el acoso escolar es un
delito ahora en Francia porque Bueno
hasta ahora era una situación que podía
ser resuelta dentro de la academia la
estructura la jerarquía la jerarquía
mayor era bueno el rector que va a
digamos que daba en una fe de una
cuestión de escolar ahora está
reconocido como un delito es decir con
las circunstancias graves que puede
llegar a las consecuencias y los
agravantes de la situación y permite por
supuesto la formación de Los
profesionales de los
que se lo tome en serio el problema y
que además se formen Y como dice La Ley
bueno se puedan reembolsar también los
el acompañamiento psicológico y
psiquiátrico de los niños pero bueno
para eso también hay Tenemos que tener
pedo psiquiatras Lamentablemente cada
vez menos
la homofobia es un motor que no está en
la cabeza del niño del Adolescente sino
que viene incorporado desde casa es lo
que hoy en sus casas no sé la educación
suponemos que tiene el valor de
contrapeso es decir un poco para pese a
tu familia el cobijo de la educación No
ese es el valor que hay que darle porque
todos tenemos las taras que hemos
escuchado en casa no
tiene que ver con que todavía se piensa
que educar es castigar prohibir o
regular no el control Entonces qué pasa
con la comunicación no cuando se rompe
la comunicación y que justamente estas
cosas cuando se habla de acoso escolar
se piensa en la víctima que se la
victimiza aún más pero tampoco se acerca
uno al agresor a ayudarlo porque
evidentemente en esa agresión está
reproduciendo algo que vive
sea en su entorno sea en su vida Pero
entonces la estigmatización de agresor
víctima no estamos hablando de
adolescentes o de niños que son víctimas
ambas partes el aspecto físico es el
principal motivo del acoso escolar en
unos instantes a vuelta de pausa vamos a
hablar de cómo funciona el aspecto
físico en redes sociales de las llamadas
de segunda generación nos lo va a
explicar Israel ahora una pausa volvemos
enseguida
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en France 24 y France 24.com
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
hablando de la crisis de la adolescencia
a partir de casos de acoso escolar y
también de la Salud Mental que deja en
nuestros jóvenes el escenario de
postpandemia lo hacemos con la
psicólogas María Eugenia uriburu y
Ariana cancio y con el periodista
especializado nuevas tecnologías Israel
Ayala el acoso escolar tras el parón
impuesto por la pandemia si se desprende
del sexto informe de prevención de acoso
escolar en centros educativos publicado
por la fundación anal en España aunque
los datos del estudio revelan un
descenso del ciberbullying la vuelta a
la presencialidad ha traído aparejado un
repunte en el acoso escolar que
presentan nuevas características tres de
cada cuatro casos son grupales y el
aspecto físico es el principal motivo
claro la en el punto de mira están las
llamadas redes de segunda generación
como tiktok o Instagram Israel Qué
tienen de particularidad Por qué las
críticas estas redes
las críticas que se hacen Es sobre todo
por la capacidad que tienen estas
plataformas en viralizar y potencializar
una agresión por ejemplo a mí me
gustaría tocar el tema de algo que está
ahorita que es tendencia en tiktok y es
cuando a las gente a la gente que tiene
afrodescendencia o que tiene la piel de
color negro
se les empieza a llamar tía Paola Y
quizá
hablar pero es verdad Claro porque para
mí es un mundo aparte pero es
impresionante es una es una acción de
racismo que está normalizada y de la que
nadie está hablando simplemente están
diciendo Bueno hay una hay una tendencia
en donde a todo lo que es de color negro
Se le empieza a llamar tía Paola porque
hubo un niño pequeño que hizo una un
comentario y a partir de eso se empieza
a viralizar se empieza a Y entonces
encuentras a la gente en la calle que
empieza a ser objeto de ataques por
simplemente por su aspecto físico porque
tienen piel negra les empiezan a llamar
tía Paola y es algo que tiene que
después los medios tradicionales tienen
que empezar a hacer su papel de bueno de
de reflexión de de criticidad no de de
ser críticos de decir Bueno lo que está
pasando en esta red pues no está tan
bien que digamos no pero las redes
sociales también lo que permiten es una
parte de anonimización es decir la
persona que va a acosar quizá
Generalmente no sabe que es acosador
simplemente lo hace porque dice Bueno
pues es una red social en la que me
mantengo anónimo doy mi opinión Y quizá
él no sabe que está acosando
indirectamente lo está haciendo pero no
lo sabe exactamente Porque fíjense otro
dato relevante del estudio es la
percepción que tienen ellos mismos sobre
su posible participación en un caso de
bullyingles Leo uno de cada cuatro
alumnos reconoce que ha podido
participar en una situación de bullying
o cyberbullying sin darse cuenta porque
esta carencia de consciencia es la
pregunta entonces justamente porque es
parte de la adolescencia en ese proceso
y en ese en esa construcción de sí mismo
que tiene que aprender el pensamiento
crítico eso tiene que ser enseñado en
las escuelas en la familia claro no como
para poder posicionarse frente a una
situación de acoso o de poder
preguntarse qué estoy haciendo Qué está
haciendo el otro no quién la está
pasando mal el adolescente no tiene
todavía la construcción del pensamiento
crítico entonces No podemos exigirle que
lo haga solo participen o participe
tiene que haber un fuerte movimiento de
educación de formación primero de Los
profesionales de la educación y también
el financiamiento en salud en Salud
Mental está vaciado o sea entonces
cuando en las escuelas tenemos pocas
psicólogas escolares que se tienen que
ocupar de cinco a seis escuelas cómo es
posible que haya un interlocutor para el
adolescente para que alguien se pueda
acercar y decir viví esto presencié esto
fui testigo no y el que es testigo al
mismo tiempo tiene esta doble juego es
que ayuda a la víctima y después voy a
hacer la víctima yo o es que me pongo
del lado del agresor simplemente para no
convertirme en víctima no es finalmente
la posición y la decisión que tiene que
tomar en ese momento
va a buscar su beneficio propio que
tampoco está mal
eso en la parte bueno en la parte del
agresor sí que dice el estudio que en
primaria destacan los problemas
psicológicos del agresor inseguridad
baja autoestima dice el estudio
frustración miedo al rechazo hay un
patrón que se repite en el agresor en
los casos de acoso en María Eugenia
bueno puede es difícil la pregunta
hay cosas que se repiten efectivamente
el miedo al otro al diferente
las inseguridades pero efectivamente
estoy de acuerdo con Ariana la
imposibilidad de pensar el hecho de no
tener esta distancia de reflexión de
sujeto digamos que son posiciones muy
de mímesis de imitación puede haber
cuestiones fenómenos de imitación Ah no
estamos hablando del mismo agresor entre
comillas pero agresores también son pero
a la vez son niños son jóvenes
adolescentes digamos es una palabra que
puede llevar a interrogarnos pero
efectivamente Está la inseguridad puede
Ay Bueno hay muchos factores que que
hacen que los fenómenos son difíciles
a detectar pero que tiene muchas
consecuencias y y toda la sociedad forma
parte de este problema y tiene que tomar
conciencia de poder ayudarlos que no se
trata de victimizar de estigmatizar a
una persona y sacarlo porque Bueno yo
reproducen en un discurso que a veces
está presente no solamente en las casas
sino también en la escuela en los
animadores en el periscolar en por
ejemplo no solamente eso sino que
también a veces la tecnología ayuda como
catarsis para la persona que está
subiendo sufriendo de acoso por ejemplo
cuando estás siendo objeto de acoso en
la escuela o por parte de tus amigos y
vas con la autoridad y la autoridad no
te hace caso que hace va a crear una
storytime de cuando me acosaron en la
escuela por no sé mi apariencia física
no Y entonces genera una especie de
catarsis en donde él va a contar su
experiencia y la viralidad de compartir
su experiencia va a ser que otras
personas compartan las mismas
experiencias y que se creen grupos de
ayuda no entonces va a visibilizar a
ampliar
sus fuentes de ayuda quizá Y eso
funciona cuando por ejemplo las
autoridades cuando va uno denunciar algo
y que no le hacen caso que no se puede
hablar con los papás que a veces es muy
común en los adolescentes o que no
tienen la confianza a veces estos medios
permiten realizar este tipo de acciones
no de catarsis ven que las redes
sociales tienen ese componente positivo
y negativo no siempre es negativo todo
lo que sucede en redes sociales también
como nos explica Israel hay un
componente muy positivo en catarsis y a
la hora de incluso de la denuncia de ese
acoso no creo que es una manera de
sentirse menos solos ya no estamos
frente a los adolescente que cuando la
pasaba mal se encerraba una habitación y
cortaba todo ahora lo adolescentes se
cierran de su habitación Pero está
conectado
por con el mundo entero o sea tienen
amigos por todos lados desde que como
decía Walter O sea hay que que poder
posicionarse y encontrar nuevos
referentes para lo adolescencia no hoy
en día la adolescencia ya no discute con
los padres sino que discute con figuras
simbólicas discute con el patriarcado
con el lenguaje no preocupados por la
ecología no la pregunta antes para mí
hay un pasaje de un adolescente de los
80 que era un Rebelde sin causa a uno de
los 90 narcisista y encerrado a un
Rebelde hoy en día que sí tiene causa y
está dispuesto a militar Y está
dispuesto a pensar en su futuro no
porque empieza la política empieza
muchísimo Antes de lo que decía antes
del ámbito ya no es a partir de votar
ahora a los 14 y 15 años mismo si antes
decía de la pensamiento crítico hay una
gran parte de la adolescencia que está
dispuesta a investigar y y a ponerse la
camiseta y a luchar por el mundo no sé
si consideran que los medios de
comunicación tenemos parte de culpa de
todo esto que hemos desconectado de
interés por los problemas de adolescente
que no nos interesa los medios de
comunicación seguir las inquietudes y
las preocupaciones de las generaciones
de adolescentes María Eugenia bueno la
problemática del acoso escolar es una
problemática de los jóvenes
efectivamente
temáticas de que suceden en tiktok son
temáticas que en los medios de
comunicación estamos muy perdidos creo
que va muy rápido y forma parte del
fenómeno de que los medios han cambiado
yo creo que a veces a los que estamos en
medios se nos olvida que también Algún
día fuimos adolescentes y lo que pasa
muy rápido y qué es lo que pasa que por
ejemplo muchas de las personas que
tienen que deciden qué es lo que va a
salir en los medios son personas que
pues ya pasaron la adolescencia que ya
pasaron no sé que son personas que ya no
ven
a los adolescentes o que no tienen los
mismos valores de los adolescentes de
ahora y del cambio generacional es
extremadamente largo y grande porque
porque los valores que para un redactor
en jefe de una redacción son válidos
Quizá no lo sea para el Adolescente y
están y yo creo que los medios están los
medios tradicionales están olvidando ver
a lo que está haciendo O sea el New York
Times Hace tres semanas que se que creó
una cuenta en tiktok cuando hay otras
otras otros medios que lo mucho más
independientes que lo han hecho desde
hace tiempo y han creado formatos que
permiten dar la misma información que da
una cadena informativa o queda una
agencia de prensa de prensa que quizá
llega a muchísima más gente a otro
público que es el público que no va a
tener a través de la televisión o a
través de la radio pero que llega a a
una sociedad que a lo mejor no tocaría
con con los canales normales
pues muy interesante todas las refl que
habían algo más sí estaba decir que
justamente que Candela adolescente crece
el adulto envejece no entonces en esta
cuestión de poder Quién es el que tiene
el saber hoy en día y que me parece
importante empezar a escuchar a los
adolescentes que tienen muchísimo que
decir ya porque voces expertas hablan de
cómo empatizar más de cómo acercarse más
al mundo de adolescente a sus problemas
esto no sé qué herramientas tiene una
sociedad para acercarse a ello incluso
los propios padres que a veces se ven
tan perdidos con redes como tiktok Bueno
yo creo que darle lugar a la palabra en
la adolescente no se trata de enseñarle
de tomar el lugar de la adolescente de
hablar como el adolescente pero de
tratar de comprender que en la
construcción que hace de su lenguaje y
hace una apropiación y hace una Bueno
una creación de la identidad también la
subjetividad
valorar la subjetividad
y fomentarla y preguntar hablar darle
lugar darle un lugar como un nuevo
crecimiento que no se conoce darse el
lugar también a conocerlo yo creo que
internet No si bien ocupado lugar de
nuevo referente no puede ocupar el lugar
los padres es necesario poder hablar y
que tengan los padres tienen que tener
conciencia de esta exposición de este
riesgos
debería haber una especie de Educación
mediática o educación hacia las redes
para que los niños porque digamos un
adulto quizás él nos yo no O sea usar
tiktok generación de 3 a 25 años no pero
alguien que tiene no sé más de 40 claro
quizá nunca va a ser su vídeo y y
publicarlo en tiktok pero pero sí quizá
dar las herramientas a los adolescentes
para decirles Oye sabes que si te están
molestando si te están haciendo esto si
tienes este tipo de comentarios puedes
hacer tomar este tipo de acciones no
Bueno pues nosotros nos hemos intentado
acercar en la medida de nuestras
posibilidades hoy a estas crisis de los
adolescentes ha sido muy interesante
tenerles aquí yo he aprendido muchísimo
personalmente de este programa gracias
Israel y a todos ustedes nos vemos en
Primera Plana la próxima semana gracias
[Música]